[Musique]
carrière pour moi malgré les apparences
nous sommes à guyancourt et non pas en
asie la ville a organisé ce samedi au
gymnase des droits de l'homme sa
treizième nuit des arts martiaux
un événement programmé tous les deux ans
dans la commune le public a pu voir à
cette occasion une dizaine de
démonstration en est fier on sait tout
le travail que cela représente pour les
associations pour les bénévoles
on sait le temps qui passe a présenté ce
spectacle parce que ça fait pas partie
de leurs attributions première de
présenter des spectacles
ils sont d'habitude ils préparent des
compétitions des cours est donc c'est
vraiment impressionnant tout ce qu'ils
peuvent faire avec les enfants qui sont
heureux d'organiser et de participer à
cette nuit des arts martiaux
au total six associations se sont
réunies pour monter ce spectacle mêlant
sons lumières et performant sportif
pendant plus d'une heure parmi eux le tk
des 78 spécialisée dans le taekwondo
on s'est entraîné sur plusieurs semaines
et plusieurs fois après les cours après
l'entraînement déjà on s'entraîne et on
continue à s'entraîner pour la démo donc
vous ça fait puis de deux mois deux mois
et demi qu à peu près qu'on s'entraîne
un spectacle également pour la bonne
cause les recettes de cette soirée
seront intégralement reversés à
l'association ime alphée ne structure
basée à guyancourt qui aide les enfants
autistes
[Applaudissements]